Matthew McConaughey is no doubt a proud
American so he did what any other proud
American would do head south to Rio for
the Olympics in route for the red white
and blue a wonderful experience ET spoke
with the texas board actor on sunday in
LA where he opened up about his special
trip to the Summer Games I was there for
one week and it feels like I saw enough
to be there for a month we really wish
my wife and I jammed we hit as much as
we could from the beach Copacabana back
to the Olympic Village and back again
ten times McConaughey is of course
married to Brazilian Beauty Camila Alves
which begs the question any friendly
rivalries between the two well at the
Brazilian u.s. beach volleyball match it
was that was their number one team
versus our 13 ring team and they kind of
buzzsaw us
they won that one pretty cleanly we had
some swim some swimming events where
there was Brazilians versus the
Americans
I came out on top of those she and I was
in the Americans here in section with
all the other American swimmers so when
a Brazilian was in the race she made
sure to get out of that sectioning go
hang out for the day next for
McConaughey his first role in an
animated film
Kubo and the two strings I kept getting
a survivor is like what films you've
done that your kids love the most look
at that they have a man bird watching
the air so that's part of the reason I
was looking for something to do with an
animated character
Kubo and the two strings is in theaters
August 19